What we have here is six
examples of possible surveys
that might be conducted.
What we want to do is critique
them, see whether they're
actually doing things that will
give meaningful results,
or results that you can
actually make some
judgment based on.
So let's read the directions.
It says, comment on the way
the following samples have
been chosen.
For the unsatisfactory cases,
suggest a way to improve the
sample choice.
All right.
So A, you want to find whether
wealthier people have more
nutritious diets by interviewing
people coming out
of a five-star restaurant.
So this is skewed on
two directions.
One, if you're only interviewing
people out of a
five-star restaurant, you're
going to have a
disproportionate number
of wealthy people.
And even the non-wealthy people
who are eating at the
five-star restaurant, they feel
like they have enough
money to eat there, so they're
probably not that not-wealthy.
They're probably pretty close
to the threshold of wealthy.
The other skew is that you're
interviewing people at a
restaurant, so you're
disproportionately probably
going to get people who eat out,
as opposed to people who
cook for themselves.
And depending on whether this
is a really healthy
restaurant, maybe some type of
organic, vegan, who knows
what, restaurant, where
you're going to get a
disproportionate number
of healthy people.
Or maybe it's a really
unhealthy restaurant.
Maybe it's they put a lot of
butter and sugar in the food.
Who knows what it's all about?
But this seems skewed
on two dimensions.
The best way to do it is, survey
some proportion of
wealthy people in an environment
where it isn't
being skewed by the type
of food they eat.
So you, once again, you wouldn't
want to survey people
at the organic grocery, because
once again, you'd be
skewing for people who maybe
eat a little healthier.
You'd want to do it maybe at
some type of wealthy type of
event, or something that's
not food-oriented.
I'd have to think more about
what that might be.
And you'd also want to survey
people who are not wealthy, so
at some other type of event
where most of the population
doesn't fall under the
wealthy category.
Or probably the best thing would
be sampling people at an
event that doesn't discriminate
on wealth, and
just surveying people and just
ask them, in a broad bucket,
do you make more than x?
Whatever your definition
of wealthy is.
Or is your wealth, or is your
income less than x?
And then ask people what do
they eat on a daily basis,
something like that
might work.
So in general, I'm not
a fan, not a fan.
I don't think this
passes mustards.
It's biased on really
two dimensions.
B, you want to find out if there
is a pedestrian crossing
needed at a certain intersection
by interviewing
people walking by that
intersection.
So this is better than the first
survey, but it still
seems a little biased.
And it depends how you
define needed.
Is needed if the people walking
around the pedestrian
crossing think it's needed,
then this is OK.
But if you want to objectively
find out whether people in
your community think it's
needed, you want to have a
broader sample.
So you might want to also
include drivers.
Because obviously, the
pedestrian crossing is going
to affect them.
You want to interview taxpayers
in general.
And obviously a lot of people
might be all of the above.
And you also might be missing
pedestrians who would be
walking by that intersection
if there was a pedestrian
crossing, but they're avoiding
it, and so those are the
people who would want it the
most, but they're not even
going to be there because they
don't think that it's worth
walking around there because
you can't cross the street.
So you're missing a whole
sample of people.
The best way I would do this
is I would look within a,
maybe a three block radius, or
maybe a six block radius, of
all of the homes and offices,
and I would randomly survey a
sample of those people.
And I think that would be a
better indication of whether
the pedestrian crossing
is needed.
And actually, even a better
way would be do
it without a survey.
You'd actually want to look at
patterns of people walking and
all of that, and compared
to other things
that might be needed.
But this one definitely
doesn't work for me.
Now C, you want to find out if
women talk more than men by
interviewing an equal number
of men and women.
That seems reasonable.
I guess if your survey, if
you do it in a non-biased
environment-- if you don't do it
at, like, a business school
or a law school where people
might talk disproportionately,
or it might be skewed towards
women or men more.
I don't know which way
it would be skewed.
But as long as you do it in a
neutral place, and I guess
their survey is, maybe they'll
ask some arbitrary question.
And they'll just time, or
they'll count how many words
the women talk versus the number
of words the men talk.
That seems like a reasonable
way to see if women
talk more than men.
And once again, as long as
you're not talking to some
skewed sample, or biased
sample, this
seems pretty good.
And it's good if it's
an equal number.
There's an equal number of men
and women in the world.
This seems to be-- I'll give it
a smiley face right here.
D, you want to find whether
students in your school get
too much homework by
interviewing a stratified
sample of students from
each grade level.
Well the first thing I want
to do is, what is
a stratified sample?
And all that means is, you're
going to sample people in the
same proportion that they
exist in the population.
So let's say that your
population-- your school--
had, say they had 100
ninth graders.
It has 200 tenth graders.
300 eleventh graders.
And 400 twelfth graders.
Actually, the school I attended
actually, it went in
the reverse order.
I think we had like 800 ninth
graders and 400 twelfth
graders since so many
people dropped out.
But anyway, we don't have
to be realistic here.
So you had a total
school population
of about 1,000 students.
So if you want to do a
stratified sample, let's say
you wanted to have
a sample size of,
let's say, 50 students.
So you wanted to sample 50
students, and you wanted it to
be a stratified sample.
What that means is, you had 100
ninth graders out of 1,000
in your school.
So 10% of your school's
population is ninth graders.
So in your stratified
sample, 10% also
need to be ninth graders.
So 10% of 5-- sorry--
10% of 50 is 5.
So you'd survey 5
ninth graders.
In both situations, this is 10%
of the population, it's
going to be 10% of
your sample.
Likewise, you had 20% were
tenth graders in the
population, so 20%
of your sample.
Or 20% times 50 is 10 tenth
graders should be surveyed.
And then 30% of your school is
eleventh graders, so 30% of
your survey.
So that should be 15
eleventh graders.
And then finally 40% were
twelfth graders.
So in this situation, 40% of
your survey, which is 20,
should be twelfth graders.
So that's all-- that's what
a stratified sample means.
Now let's talk about
whether this is
actually a good survey.
You want to find out whether
students in your school get
too much homework, and
you're interviewing
students in your school.
The one thing you definitely
will find out is you will find
out whether students in your
school think-- think-- they
think they get too much homework
by interviewing a
stratified sample.
That would be true.
That's what you would
find out.
Now, whether you could say
that in a broader sense
they're getting too much
homework, you might want to
include a larger audience,
especially the other
stakeholders in the whole
homework doing process,
especially parents
and teachers.
And actually a better way to
do it would be, probably to
compare the students in your
school to a very similar
school that has a different
amount of homework, and maybe
see the results on standardized
tests.
And you want to control.
You want to make sure that there
isn't a huge difference
between the income levels, or
the education levels of the
kids' parents, and all that.
I mean, it becomes much
more involved.
But this one still seems a
little bit narrow, and all
you're going to find out is
whether students think they
get too much homework.
And I can almost guarantee you,
they will think that they
get too much homework, and so
this survey might be a little
bit of a waste of time.
So I will put a frowny face.
E, you want to find out whether
there should be more
public buses running during
rush hour by interviewing
people getting off the bus.
So once again, what you're going
to find out is whether
people who ride, people getting
off the bus think
there should be more buses.
So I won't write it here, but
you're not going to find out
objectively whether there
should be more buses.
Frankly, the best way to
evaluate that, I think, is to
just see how full, on average,
the buses are.
I would actually poll the actual
buses and see how full
they are during rush hour.
If 90% of them are 100% full,
or people can't get on a bus
because they're full and that's
happening frequently,
and their total wait time is
just getting ridiculous,
that's probably a better
assessment than
just surveying people.
But even beyond that, this is
skewed on several levels.
One, you are surveying only
the people riding the bus.
You're not surveying the other
people in the community who
might have an opinion on this:
drivers, taxpayers who would
have to pay for more buses.
And then even within the
bus-riding population, you
have to think about when they're
getting off the bus.
If you're getting people off
the bus during rush hour, I
can almost guarantee you that
they're going to say, yeah,
we'd like more buses because
then they would have less wait
time, and the buses would be
less crowded, and they
wouldn't have to sit
next to anybody.
So even if it's not needed,
they're going to say it is.
But if you interview people
maybe getting off the bus
during lunchtime, who don't use
the bus during rush hour,
they might say no, we don't need
more buses at rush hour.
We need more at lunchtime.
So you're going to get different
answers depending on
when the people are getting off
the bus, and obviously,
you're going to get very
different answers from people
not riding the bus.
So if you want a broader
audience, if you're kind of
the city councilman trying to
figure out what to do, I, once
again, like the crosswalk, I
would survey a random sample
of people within three miles
of the bus route, or
something like that.
I think that might be
a better result.
F, F-- I'll switch colors.
You want to find out whether
children should be allowed to
listen to music while doing
their homework by interviewing
a stratified sample
of male and female
students in your school.
Once again, stratified sample
just means that, OK, if my
school is 60% male, then 60%
of my sample will be male.
And that doesn't really
seem relevant here.
F seems very similar to the, do
students think they get too
much homework?
Just as almost every student is
going to say they get too
much homework, almost every
student should say they should
be allowed to listen to
music if they want to.
And that's not going to be--
that's not really going to
answer the question of whether
children should be allowed.
If you want a broader sample,
you might-- just like the
situation with the homework--
include
parents and include teachers.
But really, if you wanted to
answer this question, the best
way would actually be to look
at, to survey students who
listen to music while doing
their homework, and students
who don't listen to music while
doing their homework,
and see their relative grade
performance, and that might
give you a better answer.
So once again, I think this
one's a little weak.
And the bus one was also
a little weak.
So the only good one here,
if it's done right, is C.
The other ones, they all needed
a little bit of work to
actually be surveys that would
give meaningful information.